[Musique]
la presse quotidienne régionale et les
télévisions locales vous
présente le club des
territoires et avec nous pour ce club
jadza bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous vous êtes essayiste auteur de ce
livre retrouver la République Samuel le
jooyeux bonjour merci d'être là
également président de l'Union des
étudiants juif de France et avec nous
depuis tel vive Daniel check bonjour
merci d'être là ancienne ambassadeur
d'Israël en France Merci à tous les
trois d'avoir accepté notre invitation
on parlera avec vous de la montée de
l'antisémitisme en France depuis le 7
octobre il y a eu plus d'actes
antisémites que durant toute l'année
écoulée on parlera du conflit entre
Israël et le Hamas de cette situation en
Israël qui poursuit ses bombardements ce
qui provoque l'inquiétude de la France
et Marion on va parler avec vous de la
question des otages oui puisque que six
familles d'otage franco-israélien et
israélien tenaient une conférence de
presse c'était à à Paris ce mardi et
nous reparlerons de leur leurs attentes
et de leurs demandes et on va évidemment
parler de tout ça d'abord on regarde
l'actualité dans nos
[Musique]
régions et l'actualité dans nos région
c'est bien sûr cette tempête Kiran qui
frappe le pays le nord-ouest du pays et
particulièrement la Bretagne qui a été
violemment touché ces der dernières
heures et justement on va à Rennes
retrouver Stéphane beignier bonjour
Stéphane merci d'être avec nous
directeur de l'information de TV Ren
Stéphane la Bretagne qui a été frappé de
plein fouet cette
nuit on va essayer de retrouver le son
Stéphane parce qu'on a on a un petit peu
du mal à à vous entendre je sais on va
essayer de de rétablir la connexion
depuis Rennes puisque on le disait la
Bretagne a été très touché avec des
records de vent qui ont été battus on
vous entend Stéphane comment allez-vous
et la nuit on imagine a été difficile du
côté de chez vous oui la nuit a été
difficile la nuit a été courte on a vu
passer vraiment les heures on se
rappelle de cette tempête du siècle
c'était en 1999 mais nous avons battu en
région Bretagne de véritabl records
cette nuit avec notamment 207 kmh
enregistré à la du rat il y avait une
très forte mobilisation 12000 sapeurs
pompiers en alerte sur tout le le Grand
Ouest et vous voyez évidemment des
images très dures heureusement pas de
victime à déplorer énormément d'arbres
arrachés il y en a plus de 250 dans le
dans le morbillant en finisterère et
bien il y a eu énormément de vagues de
submersion il y a eu des des rouleaux
haut de 12 M30 et et bien évidemment un
vent très fort dans les terres on a
l'habitude sur la côte mais là ce qui a
vraiment marqué cette nuit bretonne
c'est le fort vent partout partout en
Bretagne et dans l'Ouest il faut dire
que dans les les département de des
côtes d'armort l'électricité
pratiquement a été condamné un foyer sur
deux cette nuit les les agents d'énéice
sont sur le pont évidemment pour
rétablir l'é ricité on avait pris des
mesures les aéroports de Brest et de
quimpè ont été fermés hier à 17h ils
vont réouvrir à 9h30 ce matin on a
interdit dans certains secteurs la
circulation principalement dans le
finisterère les poids lourds ne
circulent pas et puis également les TER
et les TGV sont à l'arrêt jusqu'à
vendredi 5h du matin seulle la liaison
Renn Paris en vitesse rapide donc et
donc
éunès r viol mais l'information quand
même princip outre des arbres arrachés
des toitures dévastées quelques petits
accidents de voiture sans gravité il n'y
a pas eu de lourd blessés cette nuit en
région Bretagne effectivement c'est
l'essentiel Stéphane un petit mot
rapidement sur les conséquences de cette
tempête sur la Transa JAC Vabre
oui B la Jacques Vabre devait partir
dimanche dernier c'est une course en
équipage quatre catégories il y avait
200 marins sur l'eau et compte tenu
vraiment de cette tempête annoncée et
bien seuls les ultimes ces géants des
mers qui vont très très vite ont pu
partir à destination de la Martinique en
quittant le Havre en revanche pour les
Ocean fties les 50 pieds et les classes
40 les plus petits bateaux 12 m de long
et bien ils se sont mis au chaud à
l'Orient ils vont attendre un deuxème
départ pas avant lundi matin quant aux
Zoka les bateaux qui font le vent des
globes et bien eux sont toujours hackés
au Havre ils attendent la bonne fenêtre
météo pour partir et juste un classement
pour l'instant c'est François Gabard qui
est en tête de la catégorie des ultimes
merci merci beaucoup Stéphane on fera le
point avec vous he on suivra évidemment
cette Transat Jacques Vabre et merci
d'avoir été avec nous pour nous parler
de cette nuit difficile du côté de la
Bretagne merci beaucoup Stéphane Bier on
va passer au grand débat de ce club on
va parler de ce conflit entre Israël et
le Hamas et de ses conséquences en
France mais d'abord peut-être un mot
avec vous Daniel cheek je le rappelle
vous êtes ancien ambassadeur d'Israël en
France vous êtes actuellement à téaviv
quel est le le climat en Israël est-ce
que l'opinion soutient toujours la
stratégie de Benjamin
netaniao la stratégie n'est pas de
Beniamin netaniao la stratégie est d'un
cabinet de guerre qui est actuellement
composé de Benyamin Netanyahou et de
certains ministres dont quelques-uns
appartenaient jusqu'à il y a 15 jours à
l'opposition donc il y a quelque chose
une sorte de de construction politique
ad hoc qui qui s'est
formé je je pense que l'opinion publique
de manière générale est surtout
solidaire il y a une entraide incroyable
au moment où je vous parle c'est je
parle du quartier général du Forum des
familles des person
euh kidnappé des
otages c'est une opération de euh
société civile entièrement bénévole qui
a attiré des centaines peut-être déjà
des milliers de de bénévoles pour
soutenir ses familles de
240 personnes de l'âge de 9 mois à l'âge
de 97 ans qui s'inquièteent évidemment
terriblement pour le sort de leur
proches
donc il y a sans doute un grand élan de
solidarité un peu partout dans la
société israélienne ce qui est
évidemment très beau c'est évidemment on
aurait préféré ne pas devoir mobiliser
ce genre de sentiment dans des
circonstances tragiques comme nous les
vivons mais une fois que le
drame s'est déjà produit c'est
mieux c'est mieux comme ça et je dirais
en plus c'est une réflexion
personnelle il y a comme un nuage de
tristesse qui s'est abattu sur ce pays
les gens sont tristes parce qu'il y a eu
énormément de morts parce que ce n'est
pas
terminé parce que pour beaucoup
d'Israéliens de
voir des morts du côté palestinien ça ne
les réjouit pas
euh mais c'est le genre de chos que les
l'organisation qui a choisi le début de
ce drame c'est-à-dire le Hamas aurait dû
il pensait avant restez avec nous
évidemment Daniel cheek j Zab une
réaction à ce que vient dire monsieur
chek oui on partage aussi en France la
l'effroid de la société israélienne qui
a vécu des actes absolument abominables
le 7 octobre dernier et Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur rappelait que Monsieur
netaniaou n'était qu'un membre de cette
coalition alors je l'entends
complètement il faut malgré tout pointer
du doigt le discours qui n'a jamais été
aussi droitier de Benjamin netanahou
notamment cette semaine quand il parle
du peuple de la lumière contre le peuple
de l'obscurité il y a dans ces propos
presque des mots d'ordre messianique
presque une guerre civilisationnelle
qu'Israël devrait mener au Hamas mais en
réalité aussi aux Palestiniens et donc
moi je dis et je le dis tout le temps ne
jamais associer ne jamais assimiler la
société israélienne à Benjamin néanou
parce qu'il y a dans la société
israélienne et Monsieur l'Ambassadeur le
rappelait à juste titre beaucoup de gens
qui sont contre qui sont contre la la
dérive de du gouvernement d'extrême
droite de Benjamin netagou ensuite moi
je crois en réalité
que on s'éloigne de plus en plus hélas
d'une solution à deux états et la
position de la France doit être ferme
c'est celle du président de la
République c'est de dire oui nous
défendons le droit d'Israël parce que
c'est le cas de se défendre face au
Hamas mais dans le même temps nous ne
pouvons ignorer la réalité de la
situation sur place et je termine en 10
secondes quand Monsieur l'Ambassadeur
dit le Hamas a pris le risque oui mais
la différence c'est que l'État d'Israël
n'est pas une organisation terroriste le
Hamas est une organisation terroriste
qui n'a ni foi ni loi et donc j'allais
dire c'est très cynique on ne peut rien
en attendre l'État d'Israël est un état
qui c'est vrai ne reconnaît pas la Cour
pénale internationale mais qui malgré
tout est un État de droit et donc la
réponse d'un état de droit ne peut pas
être la même que celle d'un groupe
terroriste sauf à tomber dans le piège
qui nous étendu nous démocratie
occidentale et donc j'espère à l'heure
où on se parle qu'Israël bien qu'elle
estit un premier ministre d'extrême
droite ne tombera pas dans le piège qui
nous est tendu par le Hamas et par
toutes les organisations islamistes qui
depuis des années nous attaquent oui
oui euh une réaction simplement donc je
je je je moi je commmente pas en tout
cas la la la politique de Benjamin
netaniaou je suis d'accord avec JZ quand
il dit qu'il faut bien faire la
différence entre évidemment la politique
d'un état et sa société ça c'est une
chose par contre vous avez commencé par
dire nous en France on est solidaire de
ce qui s'est passé en Israël
malheureusement pas tout le monde et
c'est c'est c'est là que c'est c'est là
finalement qu'on qu'on commençait les
problèm en réalité euh quand on a vu les
réactions dès le 7 octobre on pouvait
prévoir ce qui se passe euh dès main ce
qui se pas jusqu'à maintenant le 7
octobre c'est le plus grand massacre de
juifs depuis la Seconde Guerre mondiale
c'est des des images on continue à avoir
des des nouvelles hein là ce matin
c'était ce viol collectif d'une femme
devant son mari pendant des heures par
des terroristes du Hamas je pense qu'on
on prend pas la mesure de ce qui s'est
passé le 7 octobre on ici on n prend pas
la la mesure de ce que ça veut dire là
on a vu des bébés qui sont mis dans un
four vivant enfin on prend pas la mesure
de l'Abomination absolue de ce qui est
de l'ordre du crime contre l'humanité de
l'ordre de la volonté de de briser une
société par des images d'une atrocité
que que je crois on avait pas vu ces
dernières années depuis très longtemps
ça c'était la volonté du ramas et malgré
tout il ça aurait dû finalement
entraîner une vague de solidarité
mondiale envers le peuple le Juif touché
dans sa chair et pourtant dès le 7
octobre il commence déjà à y avoir des
justifications il commence déjà y avoir
des gens qui vont dire oui mais et et et
et finalement il y a pas une limite qui
est mise il y a pas une conscience donc
peut-être que aussi il faut quand quand
vous dites il faut être solidaire de la
société Israél vous Visz vous visez une
partie de la classe politique alors pas
seulement je vise évidemment la France
insoumise le le NPA et ses réseaux parce
que nous on est dans les facs et dans
les fac c'est autant de c'est marginal
dans le débat public le Nouveau Parti
Anticapitaliste dans les fac c'est
important mais je vise aussi la société
je veux dire je vise aussi la société il
y a eu des paroles politiques qui ont
été importantes mais mais dans la
société ça n'est pas passer
véritablement donc voilà donc donc ça ça
a annoncé finalement la vague
d'antisémitisme qui qui suit et dont on
va parler on va évidemment y revenir
dans quelques instants mais Daniel check
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur je voudrais vous
faire réagir à ce que disait jadzad il y
a quelques quelqu instants il rappelait
la position d'Emmanuel Macron de cette
solution à deux états est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous y croyez encore à
cette solution à deux états est-ce
qu'elle n'est pas
caduque c'est la réponse est très courte
et je vais utiliser le reste de mon
temps pour en effet réagir à ce qui a
été dit la réponse est oui j'y crois
parce qu'il n'y a pas d'autres solution
maintenant il faut quand même le dire
cher
Monsieur moi je suis probablement moins
pro N que vous mais ça n'a rien à voir
c'est pas la position de Benyamin
netaniaahou et de son gouvernement
d'extrême droite que je combat par tous
les moyens démocratiques que j'ai qui a
suscité l'abomination du 7 octobre et de
la même manière que vous que vous
distinguez entre le peuple et le
gouvernement israélien ce qui à l'heure
où on se parle n'est pas justifié parce
que il y a une un front très unifié dans
ce pays même de ceux qui n'ont aucune
sympathie pour Benyamin netanahou vous
ne pouvez pas non plus dire que nous
faisons la guerre aux
Palestiniens le le Hamas et les
Palestiniens ce n'est pas la même chose
et si vous êtes pour la solution des
deux états et
pour un avenir
plus positif plus optimiste pour le
peuple palestinien le Hamas c'est votre
ennemi ce n'est pas votre
bien sûr mais Monsieur l'Ambassadeur
combien de civil Palestiniens mais Isra
tu rant c'est qui parle maintenant c'est
moi qui par après on va laisser j vous
rép que vous condamnez les violences des
col Jordan qui n' jamais été après avoir
été attaqué de cette manière peut-être
il fallait se contenter d'une plainte à
la cour pénal
international Leamas savait fort bien
qu'il y aurait une guerre qui
commencerait par une telle abomination
et c'est bien et c'est il c'est il n a
il n'y a pas d'autre choix je ne sais
pas à quoi vous vous attendez d'accord
on va on va on va faire répondre jazab
et je vous redonne la parole après
Daniel check bon alors moi je suis assez
ahurri d'entendre Monsieur l'Ambassadeur
nous dire il n'y a pas d'autre choix que
d'aller massacrer des civils dans la
bande de Gaza moi je suis le premier et
je le dis je le dis je le dis d'autant
plus que je suis un francolibanais et
que ma position en tant que
francolibanais n'est pas toujours facile
on s'attend à ce qu'un Franco libanais
déteste l'État d'Israël ça n'est pas mon
cas je suis un défenseur du droit à
Israël d'exister et du droit à Israël de
se défendre quand il est attaqué mais je
ne peux pas entendre un ambassadeur qui
par ailleurs dans l'action par ailleurs
a fait a fait beaucoup pour pour la paix
même si on n est pas arrivé un un
ex-ambassadeur d'Israël un
ex-ambassadeur d'une démocratie nous
dire nous n'avons pas le choix que
d'aller tuer des civils non je ne m'y
résous pas et donc évidemment dans la
question de la proportionalité de la
réponse d'Israël la différence entre le
Hamas la différence entre Hamas et
l'État d'Israël et que l'État d'Israël
est une démocratie avec un état de
droit État de droit que Monsieur
netanahou voulait faire basculer dans
une démocratie autoritaire avec une
réforme du système de justice mais
j'entend que l'État d'Israël a le droit
de se défendre et je suis l'un des
défenseurs du droit d'Israël à se
défendre mais la réponse de l'État
d'Israël me semble mais je suis pas
avocat en droit international très
largement disproportionné et donc
là-dessus et moi aussi Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur on se rejoint je défends
la solution à deux états je dis
simplement comment arriver à une
solution à deux états quand nous avons
des deux côtés je dis bien des deux
côtés des mort civil par centaines voire
par milliers je fais un constat c'est
tout ce que je dis Dani POS la question
au ramas pourquoi vous me la posez à moi
on on va je ne comprends pas c'est moi
qui c'est moi qui ai suscité cette
déflagration et et quand vous dites
quand vous dites que la solution
israélienne qu'Israël a choisi c'est de
massacrer des civils ce sont vos paroles
ce ne sont pas les
miennes la la solution israélienne était
de poursuivre le Hamas qui se cache
derrière sa population civile qui est le
pire ennemi des Palestiniens bien pire
que l'État
d'israëlord on va parler de la de la
question des otages he puisque céit
évidemment une équation très importante
dans ce conflit et plus le temps passe
et plus l'inquiétude grandit Marion du
côté des familles des otages oui des
otages qui sont au nombre de 240 c'était
le dernier chiffre révélé par les
autorités israéliennes parmi elles
figuraient neu français depuis le début
du conflit cinq personnes ont été
relâchées deux octogéires israéliennes
deux Américaines et une jeune militaire
horri megidich 18 ans libéré lors d'une
opération à Thérèse dans la bande de
Gaza dans la nuit de dimanche à lundi
pour le gouvernement netaniaahou cette
libération est bien la preuve qu'Israël
peut à la fois faire la guerre et en
même temps libérer des otages mais les
familles elles craignent pour la vie de
leurs proches en début de semaine le
Hamas avait lui proposé d'échanger les
otages israéliens contre des prisonniers
palestiniens ce même Hamas qui a annoncé
hier que SEP ottages dont trois
détenteurs de passeport étrangers
avaient été tués lors d'un bombardement
israélien sur un camp de réfugié au nord
de la bande de Gaza et ce mardi à Paris
six familles d' Tage franco-israélien et
israélien tenaient une conférence de
presse oui pour alerter les autorités
françaises mais également l'opinion
publique sur le sort de leurs proches
des Israéliens des franco-israéliens
dont elles nont au cune preuve de vie
elles avaient apporté avec ell des
photos dénoncé évidemment les crimes
commis le 7 octobre des crimes contre
l'humanité ont-elles dit lors de cette
conférence de presse nos journalistes
Jérôme Rabier et oppeo copola ont
notamment rencontré Olivier qui a perdu
plusieurs membres de sa famille le 7
octobre trois d'entre elles sont
aujourd'hui détenu écouter ce que lui et
les autres familles demandent
aujourd'hui ce que les familles d'otage
demandent c'est la libération immédiate
sans condition le plus vite possible
d'abord s'il n'y a pas une libération
immédiate des signes de vie et une
assurance que des ONG comme la croix-
rouge ou d'autres puissent rencontrer
les otages et pour certains leur donner
des médicaments donc il a une vraie
demande par rapport à à la Croix-Rouge
qu'elle puisse effectivement rencontrer
les otages et puis lors de cette
conférence de presse on a pu sentir le
clivage qui existe quant à la stratégie
à adopter pour obtenir la libération des
otages certains disent on ne négocie pas
avec le Hamas c'est la ligne du
gouvernement israélien d'autres il faut
penser aux otages avant tout et je vous
propose écouter à sujet deux
[Musique]
intervenantes
etes familles demandent également à la
France mais aussi à la communauté
internationale de faire pression sur le
Hamas mais aussi sur le Qatar pour
libérer les otages le Qatar où Résid
certains membres du groupe terroriste on
a entendu Dani ce ce clivage sur la
stratégie à adopter on a entendu ces
familles euh d'otage euh quelle doit
être la la bonne stratégie selon vous à
adopter face à ces otages qui évidemment
on imagine change la donne dans la
ripost
d'Israël alors
euh la l'affaire des otages et euh et le
monde dans lequel je suis entièrement
plongé depuis 15 jours je connais toutes
ces personnes la la dernière jeune femme
avec les cheveux bouclés qui a parlé
c'est une médecin elle s'appelle adva sa
sœur est enlevée oui celle-ci euh et sa
sœur est par c'est un exemple sa sœur
est atteinte de la maladie de corô elle
a besoin de médicaments elle a besoin
d'un régime particulier sinon elle va
mourir c'est très simple et euh donc
l'urgence absolue euh en ce qui nous
concerne c'est euh une intervention
humanitaire euh de la Croix-Rouge euh
pour euh euh acheminer au moins c'est le
strict minimum les besoins médicaux les
plus euh urgents pour il faut comprendre
combien de de cas de ce genre il y a eu
j'ai déjà mentionné la démographie de ce
groupe de 240 personnes il y a des
personnes âgées il y a des des
nourrissons des personnes malades des
diabétiques euh des autistes euh tout
tout ce que vous pouvez imaginer et et
bon quelle est la bonne stratégie ce
n'est pas à nous de choisir nous sommes
une organisation bénévole nous ne
remplaçons pas le gouvernement ce que
nous exigeons et ce que je pense c'est
que et d'ailleurs c'est aussi l'opinion
publique qui le pense en Israël c'est
que la priorité absolue la priorité
numéro 1 c'est le retour des
otages merci Daniel cheek merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous dans ce club je le
rappelle vous êtes ancienne ambassadeur
d'Israël en France vous étiez avec nous
depuis t av vive merci infiniment Samuel
le joyeux vous les avez rencontrés vous
ces ces familles d'otage évidemment on
imagine leur angoisse oui bien sûr je
les ai rencontré j'ai passé pas mal de
temps avec eux ces derniers jours moins
que Daniel chck mais mais tout de même
il y a deux choses que que je voudrais
dire et et sur lesquelles je voudrais
réagir d'abord vous avez vu dans le
sujet on a une famille d'otage qui
critique la stratégie gouvernementale
israélienne si un Palestinien fait ça et
retourne en Palestine il est mort dans
la demi-heure je je pense que avec la
situation il y a qume comme ça quelque
chose dans l'air d'une mise sur le même
plan d'une mise en parallèle en ce
moment entre Israël et la figure de
nthaniao particulièrement et le Hamas on
a d'un côté une démocratie qui fait ses
choix qu'on peut critiquer tout à fait
et d'ailleurs qui est critiqué en Israël
beaucoup partout dans le monde et on a
une organisation terroriste donc ça
c'est important et la question des
otages vient aussi le rappeler il y a
des femmes il y a des vieillards il y a
des enfants qui sont aux mains d'une des
organisations terroristes les les les
plus terribles les plus barbares au
monde et je rappelle quelque chose et il
y a quelque chose quand même qui me
frappe beaucoup il y a des Français il y
a des Français il y a des Français
aujourd'hui qui sont aux mains d'une
organisation terroriste abominable et et
je crois qu'il y a sur cette questionl
un détachement dans la société française
qui est extraordinairement frappant mais
mais comment il est possible que ce soit
pas dans toutes les bouches dans toutes
les têtes pourquoi ne nous j'ai
l'impression que maises personnes n'est
effrayé par le sort à la limite prenons
c'est s'agissant des Israéliens bon on
peut dire que c'est des étrangers mais
il y a des gens ce sont nos compatriotes
ce sont donc là on dit des
franco-israéliens donc quand on dit
franco-israélien je rappelle c'est des
Français donc il y a des Français qui
sont aujourd'hui aux mains d'une
organisation qui je le rappelle met des
bébés vivants dans le fou
donc donc oui ça m'inquiète et ça
m'inquiète évidemment en tant que juif
en tant qu'humaniste et cetera mais en
tant que Français et donc il n'y a pas
comme ça un mouvement de soutien global
général pour ces personnes qui sont dans
une situation dramatique ici en France
moi ça me ça me sidère et ça engendre
aussi ça accompagne ce sentiment de
solitude ce sentiment de
mal est-ce qu'il faudrait par exemple
mettre les photos de ces otages dans les
journaux télévisés comme ça a été le cas
pour d'autres otages oui mais faut
partout il faut effectivement mettre ses
photos partout et et encore une fois
parce
que mais sur les mairies mais au-delà de
l'aspect technique qu'est-ce que ça dit
ça dit que on a l'impression qu'en fait
mettre les photos de ses otages ce
serait prendre parti dans le conflit
israël-palestinien c'est ça en fait et à
un moment il va falloir arrêter ça il va
falloir arrêter de au nom de cette
pression qu'il y a autour de cette
question Israël au palestinien n oublier
complètement toute valeur humaniste on a
l'impression alors donc dénoncer
l'antisémitisme issu de la d'Israël ah
non on le fait pas parce que c'est
rentré dans le conflit Israël au
palestinien euh soutenir les otages on
le fait pas parce que non donc en fait
c'est ça la pression elle est mise
là-dessus la pression elle est que en
fait les Juifs aujourd'hui en France ils
vivent dans dans une position
d'inquiétude atroce parce que bah il y a
nos frères et nos sœurs qui sont euh
dans la bande de Gaza dans une situation
atroce il y a l'antisémitisme qui monte
et personne ne dit rien parce que euh
vous comprenez ça peut choquer je ne
sais qui d'ailleurs donc là il y a un
vrai problème et c'est ça à mon avis
qu'il faut qui sur lequel il faut se
battre Jad je suis entièrement d'accord
et je pense que cette ce que cette
question israello palestinienne a
tendance à rétrécir le spectre du débat
public et on est sommé de choisir pour
ou contre blanc ou noir et et et et
c'est c'est l'un des pièges dans
lesquels le Hamas et toutes les
organisations islamistes qui nous
attaquent depuis 20 ans veulent nous
faire tomber ils veulent nous enfermer
dans un conflit religieux ce serait
selon eux les musulmans contre les Juifs
ça n'est évidemment pas le cas ils
veulent nous enfermer dans un dans un
conflit où ce serait selon eux
l'Occident contre l'Orient ça n'est
évidemment pas le cas alors Éric Zemour
et son choc des civilisations est sans
doute le seul à croire mais sans doute
souhait-il que ça advienne aussi qu'il y
a un choc des civilisations la réalité
c'est qu'il faut le dire ça n'est pas
une guerre de civilisation ça n'est pas
une guerre de religion et en France nous
avons une communauté qui est la
communauté citoyenne et donc je partage
en effet le questionnement sur cette
forme de perte de repère moraux qu'il y
a dans la société il y a des Français
qui sont pris en otage et évidemment moi
j'espère que la France fait tout pour
qu'il soit
je pense que s'il faut qu'on négocie il
faut négocier même avec le diable parce
que ce qui nous importe aujourd'hui
c'est bien de faire revenir sur notre
sol et de faire libérer tous les otages
les 249 229 pardon otages qui sont
encore aux mains du Hamas mais
j'explique aussi il me semble que ça
n'est pas justifié mais c'est essayé de
comprendre il y a en France que
j'appelle une brèche mémorielle c'est
que pourquoi est-ce que ce conflit
israélo-arabe est si preignant pourquoi
est-ce qu'il raisonne tant avec la
société française c'est parce que nous
avons nous-même la France a été un pays
colonisateur nous n'avons pas réglé la
question des mémoires nous nous n'avons
pas fait la paix sur cette histoire et
donc il y a une pénétration du discours
que peuvent avoir le Hamas ou que
peuvent avoir les Palestiniens dans la
société je le fais rapide en gros les
colonisés d'hier ont une sympathie pour
les colonisés d'aujourd'hui grosso modo
alors que même les jeunes qui
manifestent n'ont pas connu eux-mêmes la
colonisation et donc je dis si nous
voulons nous prémunir de tout cela notre
arme on en a qu'une c'est la République
c'est la convergence des mémoires et
ayons en tête que les islamistes s'angou
dans cette brèche mémorielle pour
retourner contre la France certains de
ces enfants qui sont des binationaux qui
sont des jeunes qui sont nés ici qui ont
grandi ici et qui ont des origines et
donc je crois que évidemment il faut
condamner l'antisémitisme et il faut
expliquer que et je fais référence à
votre précédente invité Gill kepppel qui
parle du djihadisme d'atmosphère moi je
dis qu'il y a en France une forme
d'antisémitisme d'atmosphère qu'on doit
combattre résolument matin midi et soir
par une chose la raison et le principe
de laïcité qu'on a en France qu' n'y a
pas en Israël qui n'y a pas par exemple
dans une grande partie des pays arabes
c'est notre arme la plus forte il faut
la réaffirmer dans ces moments où la
République se doit de protéger les Juifs
et je termine la lutte contre
l'antisémitisme n'est pas que l'affaire
des Juifs c'est l'affaire de tous les
citoyens quel que soient leurs origines
quel que soi leur religion parce
qu'encore une fois dans le principe de
laïcité il y a un élément fort c'est
qu'en France il y a qu'une communauté
c'est la communauté citoyenne et nous
devons tous être concernés par ça pas
que les Juifs et là-dessus Samuel le JO
on rappelle que depuis le 7 octobre il y
a eu plus d'actes antisémites que durant
tout le reste de l'année écouè oui cette
vague d'antisémitisme euh
elle est particulièrement inquiétante
euh je crois que depuis que je suis
engagé ça fait maintenant quelques
années j'avais jamais
perçu un tel niveau d'inquiétude chez
les Français juifs et et moi-même en
réalité je n'avais sans doute jamais été
aussi inquiet de la situation du pays ça
pour deux raisons d'abord une chose que
j'ai dit en tout à l'heure mais que que
je crois que qui est importante à
rappeler la vague d'antisémitisme qu'on
connaît actuellement elle elle a
commencé le 7 octobre évidemment elle a
commencé avant hein on est sur un
antisémitisme don dont les don enfin qui
existe depuis très longtemps celui issu
de la haine d'Israël voilà nous on a
fait une enquête sur l'antisémitisme à
l'université la semaine d'avant le 7
octobre 43 % des étudiants juifs ont eu
affaire à une insulte ou une menace sur
cette question de la haine d'Israël bon
mais donc depuis le 7 octobre on n' pas
attendu que les terroristes aent fini de
couper les têtes des enfants en Israël
pour que déjà il y ait des remarques
antisémites en France et dans le monde
donc ça c'est quand même très violent
hein d'habitude la dynamique de de
l'importation du conflit
israelllo-palestinien dans laquelle on
n'est pas à mon avis d'ailleurs on n'est
pas dans cette dynamique là parce que
cette dynamique c'est on se venge sur
les Juifs de ce qui est fait aux
Palestiniens là ça a commencé dès le 7
octobre et juste je fin rapidement c'est
aussi inquiétant parce parce que ça
monte et on a l'impression que chaque
jour il y a une chose plus grave que que
la veille et
donc on se demande jusqu'où ça va
s'arrêter et qu'est-ce qui va pouvoir
arrêter avant la catastrophe absolue
merci beaucoup merci d'avoir été avec
nous si vous voulez bien rester encore
quelques instants on va regarder ce qu'
la une de nos quotidiens
[Musique]
régionaux et Marion c'est la tempête qui
c'est la Une de beaucoup de nos
quotidiens régionaux effectivement la
plupart des journaux évoquent cette
tempête qui fait trembler la France
comme le titre le Courrier Picard c'est
tout le car nord-ouest du territoire qui
est frappé on retient son souffle dit la
voie du Nord tout le littoral est en
alerte rappelle Sud-Ouest le journal
consacre notamment un reportage à la
commune de lacano qui se bat contre le
recul du trait de côte conséquence des
tempêtes recul estimé à 2,5 m par an en
Gironde je précise aussi qu'un qu'on
apprend qu'un chauffeur a été tué cette
nu nuit du fait de la tempête et que 1,2
millions de foyers sont privés
d'électricité enfin ce matin certains
journaux ont un coup d'avance comme le
télégramme qui propose un dossier nos
conseils en cas de dégâts et puis
l'hebdomadaire le Trégor qui conseille
lui si balade à faire après la tempête à
pied ou à vélo autour de l'agon pin Paul
et guingan espérons que les chemins
seront accessibles c'est pas pour tout
de suite l'actualité internationale fait
la une des dernières nouvelle d'alace
oui le quotidien évoque les premières
évacuations de civiles depuis Gaza et
vers l'Égypte principalement des blessés
des étrangers et des binationaux soit
près de 400 personnes c'est la première
fois que le terminal de Rafa est ouvert
depuis le début du conflit la charante
lip s'intéresse aux paysans obligés de
cumuler deux emplois et ce pour avoir de
meilleurs revenus cela concernerait en
France un/4 des chefs d'exploitation le
journal présente le parcours d'Antoine
céréalier et commercial à tiertemps et
de Dominique éleveur et chauffeur c'est
au moment de la crise du lait que
Dominique a pris ce second emploi des
situations qui révèl la réalité
économique très précaire de certains
agriculteurs un paysan ne vit plus
aujourd'hui de son travail de production
déplore la Confédération paysane de
charand on termine avec le dauphinet qui
salue l'arrivée des touristes des
touristes même en automne se réjouit le
journal de Grenoble le quotidien nous
apprend qu'alors que les stations
n'ouvrent qu'à partir de début décembre
les promeneurs sont déjà au rendez-vous
pour des randonnées ou des balades à
vélo la saison touristique s'étend donc
même en montagne pour les professionnels
du tourisme c'est une bonne nouvelle eux
qui s'inquiètent déjà de savoir s'il y
aura de la neige cet hiver merci Mario
pour cette revue de presse merci
beaucoup Samuel le joyeux d'avoir été
avec nous merci beaucoup Zab d'avoir été
avec nous également merci Marion merci à
tous de nous avoir suivi prochain
rendez-vous à 18h sens public avec
Mathieu croissand et nous on se retrouve
demain très bonne
journée